all right guys
bang bang i've got bradley back for
uh round two what's going on man thanks
for doing this
thanks so much for having me absolutely
so uh for the people who
missed out and didn't watch our first
episode together maybe just give a quick
uh kind of two minutes on your personal
background and then
what you guys are building at
unstoppable domains uh
sure so i'm from atlanta i moved out to
san francisco to do the startup thing in
2012.
uh i was working on a company that was
not crypto related
but i moved into this building called 20
mission
which was a early bitcoin hacker house
the second bitcoin exchange in the us
was launched out of our basement
uh vitalik was giving talks in our
courtyard before ethereum launched
basically everybody i met when i moved
to san francisco was some sort of a
crypto fanatic and so i bit the bug
sometime in
2013 and was going to sleep every night
thinking about it even though i was by
day working on working on
marketing software and uh eventually
eventually went uh went all in full time
on crypto in 2018
started working on ensemble domains so
there's a lot of people who would say
uh you had a front row seat you know
2013
all the way until 18 what kind of held
you back from going full time was it
just
what else you were working on was so
attractive uh or were you waiting for
something to happen to kind of jump in
uh i think you know when it was
when it was kind of the early days and
it was you know mostly bitcoin and
exchanges and things like that you know
i'm not really a
finance guy and i think that most of the
stuff that was happening was really more
around
uh finance exchanges stuff like that i
thought it was cool i thought it was
great but i didn't really see
a direct role for myself in terms of
contributing
once it got around to 2017-ish and we
got to the sort of smart contract phase
where people were starting to build
pretty cool applications that were
actually functioning in the world and
we're doing all kinds of things
that's when i could kind of get my head
around you know how
how i could participate when it kind of
moved maybe past this really hardcore
protocol
phase and more into the uh let's build
some apps that people are going to use
phase that felt more uh more like an
area
that i could contribute in got it and so
talk us through today what does
unstoppable domains
do and kind of what is the product and
how has it been going
and then we'll get into some of the
recent announcements yeah yeah for sure
so unstoppable domains is onboarding
users to
the decentralized web and for those of
you who don't know what the
decentralized web is
it is one where you control
your own content where you can put up a
website and no one can take it down
other than you
uh with the traditional web you've got
your dot com domain and godaddy can take
that away from
you uh verisign the creator of it can
also take it away from you
amazon web services can turn off your
website so you've got all of these
ways uh that the current internet ad
gets to control what you're allowed to
say and what you're not
uh the decentralized web is one where
you control it
and so what we've built is a simple
registrar like
kind of like a godaddy
unstoppabledomains.com where you can go
and you can buy domains we've also built
our own domain registries we have
crypto and zill where you can these are
smart contracts on the blockchain you
can
register domains store them inside of
your wallet and now we're building out
simple website tools so think about what
happens after
you go and you buy a domain at a
traditional registrar they then say hey
you want these tools to launch your own
website
we're doing the same thing except for
your websites are going to be on ipfs
on decentralized storage so we've got a
whole
it's the idea is that
unstoppabledomains.com is a hub
for you to go and do everything you
would want to do on the decentralized
web
got it in terms of um kind of how people
access this do they
do that through like a google chrome
browser do they need a
decentralized kind of enabled browser
how does that work
yeah so you do need browser support
because it's not part of traditional dns
and so what's happening is is that
browsers in with the decentralized web
browsers are kind of like the
the the gatekeepers they decide uh
they opt in to support this and so
we have our own chrome extension there
are some other tools that you can use
uh but there's also browsers that are
natively integrating so
opera browser for android integrated
in march i believe that was the first
time that any major browser has
supported a non-ican dns domain
extension
and there are several more browsers that
are looking at this pretty closely
uh mozilla actually just ran this fix
the internet program that we were part
of
uh over the past few months and so
they're looking very closely at
decentralized web
uh there's been kind of a turning point
this year where browsers are taking it
seriously
uh browsers are looking at crypto
wallets seriously as a method for
security so it's a pretty
uh there's a lot of these ideas that the
crypto community's been talking about
for years that are finally converging
and finally going mainstream
so when people first hear this uh you
know and i've talked to a bunch of
people they hear the advertisements on
the podcast the first thing they say to
me is like
that's a great idea no one's ever gonna
do that or
uh that's gonna take 20 years for people
to start to adopt
you guys are a shining example of like
that's not true
um and uh have had quite a bit of
success
maybe talk to us a little bit just about
like what metrics you can share publicly
uh in terms of the adoption that you've
seen and how popular
this is today and not something that's
going to happen in 20 years
yeah yeah i mean people are already
playing around right now so there's more
than 260
000 domains registered there's more than
20 000 websites live
some top websites are like kyber dot
crypto
kyber network dex there's switchio dot
crypto
there's my ether wallet.crypto i think
we got some of your podcasts up on
pomp.crypto
so there's a whole bunch of uh of apps
that are already up and out there but
there's also
just a lot of people playing around and
i think the reason why
this is going to move faster even than
the traditional internet did
is first of all it has the benefit of
the traditional internet exists and we
can use that for distribution
you can post your decentralized website
on twitter and tell people to go check
it out so we have
the benefit of distribution from the old
system but we also just have
the current internet is is falling apart
honestly
we have you know twitter hacks that just
happened we've got
uh you know chinese sensors we've got
all of these things that are causing the
regular internet to just
break in front of our eyes and that's
causing a lot of
a lot of companies to to take it
seriously and start building
so if you're adapt you don't actually
you don't actually have a fully
decentralized application
if a company can
like godaddy can just come in and take
it down like you know you may
you may have your smart contracts on the
blockchain but if no one can access it
um how does that help you so there's
some real use cases right now we also
are seeing a bunch of bloggers
and if you think about blogging it's
like the most basic form of free speech
you know here's what i think and a lot
of people in the world
if they were to go and publish on the
local blogging tools that they use
uh depending on what they say if it
pisses off some important person that
might go down
and that's not going to happen here and
i think as
as the politics around the world has
gotten so much more extreme
the demand for this has become so much
clearer
i think it's in the zeitgeist now you
know even two years ago when we talked
to people about this they're like
is internet censorship really a problem
you know is the internet
is the internet really that bad it seems
like everything's going pretty well and
this would be
that was more of an american perspective
than it was a global perspective
but now i think even when we talk to
people in america they're like yeah
man the internet is the internet's in
bad shape you know
17 year olds are getting control of you
know barack obama and
barack obama's twitter account stuff
like that man
we have a problem and guess what would
solve that problem
if you had a private key that was
securing your account that's how you
unlocked it
so you know we have the solutions
already in our world we use them you
know you and i probably use them every
day
so the solutions are there the problem
is glaring
and now we just have an onboarding
problem and that's
that's that's really what we're trying
to solve we're just you know one by one
trying to bring users over
and so obviously the uh dot crypto or
dot zill
domains the these literally unstoppable
domains which is a great name for the uh
for the business
um are able to be used for uh kind of
the destination
or the public address if you will for a
website but you also can use them for
wallet addresses as well and so maybe
talk a little bit about how you can use
you know pump.crypto or whatever
for a wallet address yeah
think of think of them as like the the
gateway to the decentralized web so
you know a blockchain domain can be used
for your website
it can be used to receive money kind of
like your venmo account
uh it can also be used for messaging we
just launched a
chat protocol where you'll be able to
message me brad.crypto we can message
back and forth
brad.crypto and pumpdoc crypto and
that's a decentralized encrypted
uh encrypted messaging system and so
when you do it that way you've got
so you can send me money to brad.crypto
you can check out my website so if i'm
you know showing you some sort of
marketing advertisements when you pay me
you'll know that you're paying the same
person when you message me to discuss it
you'll know you're talking to the same
person so you don't have to go back and
forth across platforms
and that prevents all kinds of these
phishing scams that we see you know i
got to talk to you on telegram over here
i gotta send message to some email box
over here
i can't tell if i'm talking to the same
person we can guarantee you're talking
to the same person
in this paradigm uh but the way that it
works on the money side
is so i've got brad.crypto i attach all
of my crypto addresses my bitcoin
address my ethereum address my litecoin
address
whatever i can attach up to i think
there's 70 currencies supported right
now and theoretically any currency
uh and then you can just go into a
wallet and and pay so
i don't need to ask you anymore what
currency you want to receive i don't
need to ask you what your addresses are
i can just pump dot crypto i can just
type it in and send money
and so you have to have this big
announcement now with uh with coinbase
maybe talk a little bit about
what exactly is the announcement and how
does it work
for users and also technically yeah
so coinbase wallet now supports
uh sending money from using dot crypto
and
zero domains and so the way this works
is i can just go into this end field
uh inside of any currency inside of
coinbase
wallet type in brad.crypto and send
money
and what's happening i mean it's so it's
so simple
to the point where it's hard to imagine
in 10 years
people are going to be using addresses
uh just like no one uses ip addresses
in order to find websites and i think
it's going to be the same here
because this is easier and it's just as
secure
because the domain name is an asset on
the blockchain too it's stored by you
so any information that you update any
crypto address you add whatever
you have to sign a message with your
private key so any updates
you're the only person that can make the
update unstoppable can't make an update
unstoppable can't take the domain away
from you
your wallet can't make an update your
wallet can't take the domain away from
you
and so because you have that dynamic
it enables you to trust a
a human readable system instead of a
non-human readable system
and it may be that people will still use
addresses like machine to machine
uh but maybe not even there like maybe
it'll actually be a good idea
to give every single smart contract a
name too just
just to have just to have you know
simplicity
um when you're writing code so i don't
see
why the current addressing system is
going to be
used much for you know day-to-day
payments in the future
and so i guess as part of this uh it's
kind of history repeating itself
right which is there was a point in time
where to use the internet you had to use
ip addresses to
get around and so literally you have to
either have memorized or have written
down
here is the exact sequence of numbers uh
in order to get to a certain destination
when we had urls uh used that were kind
of human readable
complete game changer i don't have to
remember you know a random sequence of
uh
numbers i now can just know google.com
right or unstoppabledomains.com
and so that is uh an inflection point in
terms of internet adoption and usage
i'm assuming that you guys uh expect
something similar here but maybe just
talk through
you know once everyone is able to send
uh
cryptocurrency to a human readable
domain
what's the impact and kind of how do you
guys think about how this kind of
sequentially plays out and if it is an
inflection point
i think what we're seeing here is a
little different than what we saw with
the traditional internet where we're
actually seeing
convergence so you know in the old world
you know you have
you know your website address over here
you've got your payment address like
your venmo or your paypal account over
here
you've got your communication address
which is like your facebook messenger
account or your email address or
whatever
all of these are separate things and
what you're getting with the
decentralized web is
everything's rolling up into this one
thing so this the domain can do all of
those things
and so what's going to happen is is that
you're going to have this
uh identity so to speak that can do all
of these different things
and so it's going to help all of the use
cases because i know
that when i'm sending money to
brad.crypto it's the same person
whose website i'm looking at it makes me
more comfortable to send
so it is going to so the usage of
decentralized
websites will increase the usage of
crypto payments
the usage of decentralized messaging
will
will increase the usage of decentralized
websites
the increase of crypto payments will
increase so all of these use
cases are going to be playing into each
other in this way and so i think that
this sort of onboarding phase
is the shift that we're going through
right now
where we're transitioning from a kind of
uh developer focused set of products
where you know we have to learn even
non-technical folks have to learn
you know all kinds of stuff about
private keys and whatever
uh into a user-focused
state where we can communicate to people
hey
here's your you know blockchain id
essentially
you can go and use it for all of these
things so we're in early days of that
shift
but the shift is now possible so i think
that what we're
the phase where we're at if i were to
define it
is uh we're in the tunnel and we can
start to see the light like we can start
to see like
what is this going to look like in 10
years how is this going to work
how are these two or three billion you
know internet users how are they going
to adopt and i think it's going to be
through stuff like this
you know you go you get an id
you share it with your friends you use
it for all of these things
it's very tangible for people
so i think that's where we're at the
beginning of being able to see what the
future looks like
yeah and the part to me that's so
interesting is similar to how you can
put your
website url out in the world and you may
send it directly so i could send you
an exact url and i want brad to go and
visit it
or i could post it on my twitter account
and anyone who comes across it can click
and do that
that kind of one-to-one ver and also
one-to-many
um adoption of urls created
opportunity to do things that we just
didn't ever imagine
right so we've seen people do all kinds
of crazy stuff with the internet it
seems like this is very similar where
today most uh addresses are used in a
one-to-one scenario so
you say hey i want to send pump some
money right i go ahead and i send you my
address you then send it
when all of a sudden now i can simply
post pomp.crypto anywhere
you really can open up the use cases for
cryptocurrencies you can drastically
increase
you also make it easier for businesses
right you probably reduce a lot of
kind of fraud and all the craziness and
so it feels like this is just a net
positive across
many different facets of the crypto
world
um and getting coinbase on board makes
it you know
not only the net positive but it's like
you know on steroids because you've got
the largest u.s exchange
supporting this now yeah and i think
that one-to-many
is very astute i think that is a very
that is a powerful that is a powerful
dynamic that hasn't really been unlocked
yet in crypto
and i think what we're gonna start to
see relatively soon are things like
uh like viral donation campaigns
you know like hey crypto community let's
all get together
and let's donate you know million
dollars to this cause
and you could have the payment address
go viral on social media you know you
don't even need
you won't even need to offer any more
steps you'll just say
hey here's this you know awesome cause
pay here nothing else like that alone
is all the information that you need so
it's really really really concise and i
think that's that's going to be powerful
in terms of coinbase you know i mean i
think it's you know obviously it's super
exciting for us coinbase is you know you
know
pinnacle crypto brand uh but i think
what we're really seeing at this point
is we're seeing ubiquity for
uh for blockchain domain names like
pretty much
you know pretty much every major crypto
wallet at this point
is is adopting this technology and so
we're getting to this point where
you as a user are going to be able to
really not
not really worry too much about you know
which app you're using or having
to think too hard about that that it
really is going to be this
this uh this feature that you can just
use
across the crypto ecosystem without
thinking about it and i think that's
what's required in order for it to
really
uh for it to really catch on you know it
can't work in 10
of apps you use it needs to work in you
know 90. so
we're getting to that point and in terms
of uh
if i go ahead i've got a coinbase
account i want to attach
pom.crypto can i send that to people and
they can
uh basically on coinbase go ahead and
just send me bitcoin or whatever
uh and they can do it from their google
chrome browser or do they also need to
be in a decentralized support
decentralized web supported browser they
don't need a special browser for this
but you do need to be using coinbase
wallet so this is coinbase self-custody
wallet not coinbase.com which i know is
a little bit confusing for folks
because they have similar names um so
this is coinbase wallet self-custody
wallet
um which has uh which supports a bunch
of different currencies and so you don't
need a special
browse or anything like that you just
need to go and use it from your phone
so if you don't have coinbase wallet
already i'd suggest you check it out
it's a great wallet um it has a great
dap
browser um a couple of other cool things
about it you can also
see that you can also store the domain
inside of coinbase wallet so they have a
little collectible section the domain
shows up you can see a list of them
and if you go to unstoppabledomains.com
from within the dap browser
you can manage your domain so because
your domain is sitting inside of your
coinbase wallet when you go into the dap
browser and you want to make an update
you can sign a message with the private
key right there so coinbase wallet is
this like one stop shop where you can do
it's essentially you've got access to a
domain registrar where you can do all of
your updates
you've got a little storage mechanism
where you can see it
and then of course you can use it for
payments and in terms of
um individuals versus businesses
where have you guys seen so you
mentioned you know 200
plus thousand kind of domains registered
20 000
plus usage all that kind of stuff like
are you seeing businesses adopt this
stuff yet or is it still mainly
individuals who are
kind of at the forefront of usage
there's a lot of crypto companies
there's a lot of crypto companies that
are putting up
uh either you know if you're a dap
you're going to put up
a front end you're going to put up your
front end on ipfs
and so you can have everything kind of
fully function as long as you don't have
a back end it's extremely easy
so we're seeing a lot of those cases
dapps we're also seeing
a lot of these kind of i would say it's
kind of like smbs almost you know people
who
are working on various types of crypto
projects that are relatively small
not as professionalized as maybe an
exchange or a wallet
that are building apps and websites and
then you also just have the kind of
crypto enthusiasts
so it's a mix but in terms of the raw
number
it's more of this like smb individuals
company wise there's there's just not
enough
crypto companies um so there's i think
maybe a few thousand crypto companies
that have claimed domains
uh of which you know people are in
various stages of building websites
and how do you think about you've got
coinbase now supporting this
there's you know probably hundreds of
wallets that that are out there
um kind of you guys methodically walking
down and getting
uh each one of these walls to support uh
unstoppable domains
well we want everybody to support it and
so we're you know we're talking we're
talking to everybody and if we're not
talking to
if you have a wallet and we're not
talking to you yet please please reach
out
um we'll we'll make sure and find a way
to you know
find a way to work together that's
that's exciting and beneficial for
everybody
um but yeah i mean we're we we are
reaching out the goal is to have
you know 100 adoption across the wallet
community i think that's what the user
expects
i think anything short of that is
actually a little bit a little bit of an
inferior user experience
so we're we're going to keep we're going
to keep pushing until we get there
i continue to tell people that uh it's
scary
right if you send any sort of real size
of
uh money or bitcoin you end up literally
kind of your hearts
uh pumping really hard and you're like i
hope i don't mess this up right
you gotta check every single uh you know
letter and number and an address
yeah and it's a it's a it's a stressful
way to have to
to have to send money and it really
it's really it's not necessary like
there we can get
we can get feedback loops so what the
wallet is doing right now is when i type
in the domain the wallet is reading the
blockchain
and finding an address but the wallet
can go and confirm
any number any number of bits of
information before i send
and that's much closer to how it works
in the regular world you don't just
you know send random money to an
anonymous account
without having any kind of feedback like
you you have some
level of of assurance that this is the
right person and
you know with crypto networks i think
you can do that times 100
you know you can have data provably
you know verified provably verified you
can have multiple data
data types provably verified so i think
uh
this is a temporary problem for sure
and uh before we go on to talk about
kind of the future
uh anyone who is watching please go and
uh try it out it's awesome i've got
pop.crypto but go to
unstoppabledomains.com
you can go and get a url there um brad
let's talk a little bit about
uh kind of what unfolds next right so we
get to a world where
um every wallet is supporting or a
majority of wallets are supporting
these human readable domains obviously
people start to uh
actually build websites uh do you think
that that leads to kind of
mass adoption of the decentralized web
uh browsers
do you see kind of uh the new york times
and the washington post and kind of you
know really large organizations starting
to
create a mirror version in the
decentralized web that they haven't
centralized one
like where are we going i think we're
going to see a few
kind of circles of adoption i think
adoption circle number one is the crypto
community
uh the crypto community absolutely needs
a decentralized web
like if you're a defy app if you're a
dap of any kind like you have these
points of failure
your domains are at risk it happens all
the time there's been all kinds of
crypto companies that have
had issues with their uh domains or with
hosting services or whatever
another crazy thing is is that some of
them have jurisdiction issues where they
don't actually want to be in control you
don't actually
you know let's say you have a dow or
something you don't actually want to put
one individual in control
you can actually put a group of people
and they can vote
on control of the domains you can
actually take it out of the
you know take it out of the control of
any one individual
so i think where we're going right now
is crypto community is going to adopt
because
they need this technology it's a core
problem they have right now
then i think the next wave are people
around the world
that don't have access to a free
internet people who
are in places where takedowns are are
common
and i would think about places like
india and china and russia
actually most of the world actually
unfortunately lives
in a place where the internet is not
free and so there's a strong need
you know whether it's blogging whether
it's
e-commerce whether it's you know kind of
whatever you're trying to do online it's
hard to do
and you're getting restricted you're
getting taken down you're getting
blocked you're having to ask permission
from this or that government official
for months and months
so the next wave after the crypto people
is going to be
uh people who are struggling to use the
regular internet
i think the final wave is going to be
the
kind of new york times or these other
like enterprise companies and the reason
they're going to do it
is because it's cheaper and the reason
it'll be cheaper
is because right now when you want to
buy hosting
you call up amazon and amazon says yeah
i built another server farm and wherever
and i'll sell you some space but in the
future what's going to happen is you're
going to be able to access
anybody's storage space anywhere in the
world
in a marketplace and it's going to be
far more efficient and far more cheaper
and far less risk
of uh of takedown of
ddos of all of these issues that we have
right now
because you'll have your content
distributed so
phase one crypto companies because they
absolutely need it
and they're also native to the tech
phase two
uh people that are getting censored they
absolutely need it they're not native to
the tech but they'll figure it out
because they don't have a choice
and then phase three is going to be hey
this is just a better way
to run new yorktimes.com than
the current system that you're using and
that is way further down
in the future but mathematically i think
it's it's very easy
it's very easy to see that a distributed
web
and distributed storage is going to be
far more cheaper
far safer and far more performant so
the current web is going is not going to
be able to compete
um but that is that is going to be a
longer-term transition i think we're on
a
we're on a 20-year ride here uh and i
think we're in the crypto phase right
now which could last even for the next
you know
we could be on we could be in the crypto
phase even for the next three to five
years
but the nice thing is the crypto
community is actually
quite big i mean i'm sure you feel this
sometimes you know if you if you go out
and you start talking to
to normies and you want to start talking
about what's been going on and you
realize oh wow i have to like
take it from the top i've been so deep
in my bubble for so long
uh but it's a really big bubble so i
think that
um we have this conversation with people
sometimes where they're like
you know if this is just a crypto thing
how big is it
and we're like do you realize how big
crypto is
just today like we could build a
massive fully functional alternate web
right now just with crypto people and so
that's why we're just so focused on that
because we we think that's where the
that's where the most growth is going to
be in the short term
so uh long answer
it will replace the current internet you
will be able you will get to a place
where the new york times is
decentralized too
um but not anytime soon
yeah and then what about uh mobile
applications so we've talked a lot about
kind of more web type applications when
you think of decentralized web
a great example would be like the tick
tock uh controversy right now should it
be banned should it not
i think kind of hits home or is more
obvious to uh people in the united
states than uh than other examples
um can things in the mobile space
uh whether they're mobile first or
mobile only uh can they benefit from the
decentralized web today or is it just
things that are more web-based
they could and and and and it
it gets down to the architecture of how
it actually of how these systems
actually work and the problem with tick
tock is
the data is sitting on tick tock
databases uh
not sitting with you and so a future
decentralized tick tock
would have your videos your
profile data your likes all that sort of
stuff
sitting on ipfs or another decentralized
storage network controlled
by you when you go and open up
decentralized tick tock you'll sign a
message with your private key
and you'll give that application some
permissions to do something
with that data but you'll control it so
if you say something that decentralized
tick tock doesn't like
nothing they can do about it you control
that you control that data
now they might try to ban you as a user
but you can just go to decentralized
tick tock number two
and you still have your data so you take
the power
away from the company and you put the
power in your hands
and we see this with youtube already
like youtube has been going
and just knocking down crypto crypto
influencer after crypto influencer over
the past few months
and the reason why that's so uh why
that's
so harmful to those influencers is
that's the place where they are on the
internet those videos
often times aren't anywhere else so you
go and take that down that's their
database
of their content and now it's just gone
inaccessible in the future it's not
gonna happen like that
you're going to control your data
youtube gets permission
to show it to their users and if you
don't like what youtube's doing
you go to youtube number two or maybe
youtube number 45
because that's really just a ui we need
to take
this power the reason why companies why
tech companies have gotten so powerful
and have gotten so abusive is because
they control
the data they are also a database
they're an app and they're also
our database storage and we need to pull
that database storage piece
out of their business model and let them
just be these apps
because they're actually pretty good at
being apps
yeah and and so let's go back in before
we close up
in terms of coinbase itself this
announcement um
talk to us about uh kind of what you
guys have had to do technically to make
this
uh viable for coinbase and what is your
pitch to
uh individuals who have a coinbase
wallet uh
in terms of why they should be using an
unstoppable domain rather than the
the traditional wallet address yeah i
mean in terms of the actual wallets
we're trying to make it super easy so
we've got integration tools we've got
libraries and things like that
it's pretty lightweight for for wallets
so it's really just a
you know it's really just a decision for
them to make hey like
do i want to support this um this new
tech i think it's you know it's usually
like a
couple day kind of adventure for them
it's not a it's not a very serious thing
um it's it's similar to other types of
reads that they're probably already
doing on the blockchain so
pretty simple uh in terms of users i
mean i think you um
you know the value to users i think you
you you said it
every single time you want to send money
you need to
sweat and stress over every single digit
and every single letter and make sure
that it's right
and maybe you'll make a mistake and lose
your money and so if you
are sending to a domain
you don't have that problem you can just
use your
you know use your eyes and check the
word and make sure that the word is
right
uh and then you're fine so i think
that's the that's the value proposition
is this is the way to safely
and easily send each other crypto
for sure and and i guess um kind of in
closing
are there examples of either
individuals or companies that are doing
this really really well
that you would say hey if you're
interested in this and you kind of want
to see an example or two
that people can either go see or is the
best thing to do just send them to
unstoppabledomains.com and they can kind
of see some examples there
i would go to unstoppabledomains.com i
would also just open
up coinbase wallet and type in
brad.crypto and just see it
don't send me money i don't need a tip i
don't
um but i'm just giving you a short
domain name to check out
uh that's the easiest mental that's the
easiest way to take the mental leap
if you just see it you'll be like yeah
that that feels kind of like venmo that
feels much more like
how i think payments should work much
more so than
copy and paste some random address from
one wallet and then put it into it
and then go and take it into another
wallet and then double check and triple
check and
uh and all of these steps so i think
that's just uh
i think it's obvious once you see that
once you see it in action
i thought you were about to pull a
fundraising move right there and just
say hey just send me all your money
no we got to be really careful so i
never
and i'll just say this now i never ask
for money
should um yeah just
i'm the exact same way um all right guys
listen
uh you know obviously brad and i have uh
uh recorded an episode before
um and i was really really intrigued by
what they're doing uh to me this is a
no-brainer
right it's something that does uh kind
of three things one is it heavily
incentivizes people to move into the
decentralized web
uh two is it makes it super easy like
you don't have to be a genius you don't
have to
uh have memorized these long strings of
numbers and letters anymore you now can
use these human readable
urls uh and then the most interesting
part to me is
integrating uh these human readable urls
with existing products so coinbase
wallet is
a no-brainer and probably kind of the
the top product to go after
uh but i think that you'll end up seeing
this in a bunch of other
um you know products that you use and so
the the number one thing
when people ask me about it is just go
get your domain
like that's like step one right is if
you want to
uh believe that this is going to happen
or you've got to deeply say that it is
happening
go get your domain it's just like on the
normal web
you run over to godaddy or any of these
services and you try to get the url of
your choice
uh there's only one of them so go head
on over to
unstoppable domains and uh and grab your
uh your domain
brad any last closing words here for
people as uh
as we hopefully have shed some light on
this uh
momentous occasion for you guys and for
coinbase
i mean we're obviously super excited but
i would just say the decentralized web
is is actually happening this year 2020
2020
is the first year we can say that uh
with any kind of confidence like we're
seeing real apps we're seeing websites
we're seeing we're seeing domains out
there in the wild like it's very
different than even a year ago
so there's a lot of uh there's a lot of
action
uh don't sleep on d web everyone's
talking about d5 d5 is amazing i'm a
huge g5 fan too
but don't sleep on d web that might be
the best tagline of all
is don't sleep on d web right my friend
thank you so much for
for taking the time to to do this i
think people are really going to enjoy
it and everyone go check out unstoppable
domains